[Music]
we're on track to hit the highest annual
average growth rate in over 13 years and
I will say this right now I'll say it
strongly as the trade deals come in one
by one we're going to go a lot higher
than these numbers and these are great
numbers once again we are the economic
envy of the entire world when I meet the
leaders of countries the first thing
they say invariably is mr. president so
nice to meet you
congratulations on your economy since I
was elected we've added 400,000 new
manufacturing jobs remember that was the
obsolete deal obsolete I used to say why
is it obsolete we have to make things
manufacturing jobs are among our best
jobs and we're just getting started that
was President Trump earlier today
literally going over what is now a
remarkable economic story since he has
now taken office these unprecedented
numbers certainly sure to help
Republicans we are 101 days away from
what I am calling the most important
midterm elections in our lifetime now
earlier this week Breitbart news they
came out with a very thorough report
detailing seats that the GOP must
maintain and hold to keep their majority
a lot at stake joining us now former
Trump White House chief strategist Steve
Bannon
here's the thing Steve you and I have
discussed this privately this is now
battlefield 2018 because they want to
impeach the president
they want their crumbs back they want to
get rid of ice open borders they want to
keep Obamacare and they want to cover up
the corruption that we have been
exposing at the highest levels of
government to steal an election a lot at
stake Shawn you said something that's
the most important midterm I would just
like to rephrase that and I think this
is president Trump's first reelect this
is going to be an up or down vote
it's a referendum on the Trump
presidency they are very focused the
opposition is gonna be very focused on
trying to win the house representatives
try to win Congress in order to impeach
the president from and stop the entire
project right whether it's the economic
growth whether it's the new
reorientation of the world's crime
chill system through trade deals whether
it's his America first national security
whether its southern border security you
pick it they're gonna try to unwind it
so this is really I mean the Democrats
got one thing they got to do over in
this November and it's a hundred days in
a wake up a hundred days and a wake up
we're going to have essentially a
national election and that's going to
determine the the second half of the
first term of President Trump and I
think 2020 so people to ask about 2020
right now we are going to have a
referendum it's going to be I think very
focused on president Trump's record and
I would tell everybody that we're the
way to win this is exactly like we won
in 2010 that great tea party sweep
you're going to have to go at
door-to-door ring doorbells and do voter
registration drives and get people out I
mean President Trump has delivered on
the action now it's time for the
populist movement the nationalist
movement the Republicans let me
government serves everybody conservative
everybody that turned out in 2016 you
have to do it all over again
or they're the first action they are
going to take under Nancy Pelosi or
whoever the Democratic speaker is is try
to impeach President Trump you know I
went through the numbers your old
hometown Breitbart I think it's a great
piece great piece but it identifies only
a hundred seats are really up for grabs
the others are safe because of
gerrymandering et cetera but so they're
not in play but you got eighty six of
those are Republican seats and you're
talking about the Republicans got to win
61 of the 86 so that's a lot and
historically and I asked the president
about this earlier today on my radio
show historically seats are lost in the
midterm election for the for the party
in the White House
how do people save these 61 seats Plus
because I'd like to have a little
comfort large in there here's what you
have to do we did look we picked up 62
or 63 net seats in 2010 and it's not
about money it's about ideas and it's
about it's about getting out and turning
out folks President Trump has deliver he
said he was going to take action he took
action was a destruction of Isis he took
action was look at these economic
numbers today did they're just
unbelievable look what he's doing on the
and the trade deal is what he's doing is
really
orienting the world supply chain away
from China he is fully engaging and
going back on China on the economic war
they've had on us
president Trump has delivered on judges
everything he said he was going to do
he's either done or in the process of
doing and it's a combat upon everybody
that supported him at 2016 this is gonna
be the old-fashioned way okay this is
not going to be about commercials it's
not how much money you raise this is
gonna be very simple it's gonna be
muscle the the opposition is is very
different than in 16 and 16 Hillary
Clinton's arrogance their cockiness you
know they really missed what we were
doing in the Upper Midwest okay to
really break that blue wall this time
the the time's up movement and the
resistance are very focused and they're
going door to door it is incumbent upon
everybody that supports president Trump
to understand this is gonna have to be
the old-fashioned way
you're gonna have to so to door you're
gonna have to have camp let's get voter
registration knock on doors and get your
neighbors to come in this is all about
turnout on November 6 so we're calling
this banning battlefield 2018 and
tonight you're giving us like a generals
overview as we now get to the hundred
day countdown in this but next week
we're going to specifically do is we're
going to name every district and put it
up on the screen the audience could see
here's the thing because there are some
people that rightly will look at their
congressman and they'll say to me and
you hannity panin my congressman's a
rhino my senators a rhino you're asking
me to go support this guy i went out and
supported trump but the stakes are so
high what they want to do to the Trump
agenda which is the answer at least
that's my answer I don't wanna put words
in your no this cuts the heart of it
this is a national referendum whether
it's a rhino whether it's an
establishment figure whether it's
somebody either congressman or a senator
that you don't fully support that is not
the question now the question is about
the Trump agenda the question is about
President Trump in his agenda and you're
going to have to just put you know
you're going to have to sometimes vote
for people that you're not totally
comfortable with okay and this means
some establishment figures some rhinos
it doesn't matter this is a national
referendum it's an up or down vote on
the trump presidency if we take enforce
everything to November 6 we're gonna win
this there's not going to be a
Ravin here's the benefit of not having a
blue wave when they don't get the blue
wave that they've been selling their
grassroots people they're gonna have
they're going to turn on themselves on a
civil war in the Democratic Party
I gotta he's gonna make 2018 2020
Morrie's women you just motivate there's
a bigger and it's already developing you
just look at the job numbers put aside
the success North Korea and yes we now
have remains from that war coming home
this very day and no more rockets being
fired in a dismantled nuclear test site
and then the Iranian dearly promised to
get out of Jerusalem's the capital and
the toughest sanctions we put on Russia
but more importantly we now have record
low unemployment in this country in 14
states for women in the workforce
African Americans Hispanic Americans
Asian Americans and the military that
have been out of work and millions now
have been taken off the Food Stamp rolls
with more jobs available than people on
unemployment this didn't happen as fast
when Reagan was president who you know
I'm a Reagan conservative if you look at
the actions he's taken and you look at
the results we already have including
the judges and the redoing of the
federal judiciary it's been nothing
short of extraordinary
Donald Trump is a historic president
Donald Trump's a transformational
president if you want to keep that
transformation going that's why this
November is not a midterm election this
midterm is the first reelect of Donald J
Trump and everybody's going to put their
shoulder to the wheel it's exactly Shawn
as you remember what we did in August of
2016 we brought the Republican
establishment together the Trump
movement together grassroots
conservatives together we put our heads
down and against tremendous opposition
in of the media the opposition party
media and all the money the Clintons
raised it didn't make a difference we
won and we won big in a historic
landslide that can happen again and it
will happen again if people start to
focus on what November 6 is which is a
national referendum on the presidency of
Donald Trump all right let me tell
everybody so we're gonna bring you on as
often as you can I know you travel a lot
pretty much once a week from now to
election eight and so everybody knows
Steve does not like doing TV but you
think this is so important that you want
to identify we'll do this next week we
will identify every single district
that's going to matter where
they're the real well battle like
battlefield a battlefield man and battle
fight 28 will show people Shawn you've
been so gracious to talk to me about
this is that I think people need to
focus on where this battle is going to
take place and it's going to be you know
people are going to have to put their
shoulder to the wheel you know it's game
on
and you know we have to leave everything
on the field in no tears I I'm tired of
hearing the whining particularly our
side of the football
about you know this candidate that
candidate we got to stop the whining we
have to get focus and what's needed for
victory you have a hundred days and a
wake up to do it alright badan
battlefield 2018 next week we identify
the defining races in this upcoming
midterm Steve thanks for being well
thanks for having Shawn